foreign
let's go out to Chattanooga Tennessee
right down the road and talk to Mario
what's up Maria
hi thank you so much for taking my call
of course I'm an incredible singer so
thank you for letting me sing your name
what's up you did great
before your show
anytime somebody says oh you did great
that means you did terrible you did
terrible what's up and uh your show has
helped me on and off for the last one
major thing do you think um for having a
program like this so I'm calling today
because I'm struggling with balancing
out
I don't know the reasons for making a
decision so pause baby step two
so that we can help our
14 year old who attempted suicide a year
and a half ago
find purpose focus and Hope
um whilst also not putting our family at
risk of
you know remaining in in this debt
situation so for people listening who
don't understand her reference you guys
Maria your family y'all are paying off
you're trying to get out of debt you're
trying to pay all your debts off right
yes sir and then you have a 14 year old
girl who is really struggling
yes yeah she's doing well right now
um we've we've come a long way and
um
it was a quote-unquote real
suicide attempt she um ended up in ICU
for three days and then in a uh for a
massive overdose of Tylenol which would
have killed her if he hadn't been on the
phone with a friend who said you should
call 9-1-1
and she then was admitted to this I'll
call it a stabilization facility that
caused more damage than good she was
just a new 13 year old and they put her
in there for 10 days and we had no
control over it and she was with
you know kids up to 17 years old who had
drugs and sexual and
violent abuses and all this other thing
and so now what she's dealing with is
just the trauma from that to help her
move forward but we have helped her she
did get the best
dialectic behavioral therapy treatment
it was a full inpatient treatment for
about six to eight weeks and she meets
with a therapist weekly and what's her
official diagnostic borderline oh oh
sorry oh no no major depressive disorder
and generalized anxiety and she also
developed ticks and she's not ADHD but
she has a focused problem and we're also
thinking there's a little bit of this
lovely what is it called opposite
oppositional
um
at some point they just start throwing
everything up against a wall right right
I mean it's just like right I want you
guys to think
um
I want you guys to think outside of the
diagnosis okay
obviously she's seeing a professional so
let the professional do the professional
things
um what she needs at home
is a stable
um
yeah warm peaceful home
yep yep and
go ahead
I was going to say yes that is something
that we uh she does have a she's not
just saying no the background
a very small very close family she's our
only child
um and we do have um her uncle lives
with us he is my brother and he's a
special needs adult and he's fully
functioning and so that's the family
unit we don't have any other close
relatives nearby what was her story as
to as to why what led up to because yeah
that didn't happen in a vacuum for
someone that young that's right
um we haven't gotten a direct answer
from her the way that this whole thing
started was that beginning of a seventh
grade
towards the end of seventh grade I guess
beginning of eighth grade
um we got a call one day
oh sorry sorry
or so our Behavior started changing she
started not talking with the friends we
would normally hear her laughing and
giggling with and this was during covid
um and she started wearing like darker
clothing which were like okay you're a
teenager you're gonna try to find your
look your Vibe whatever your group
um and she just seemed a little more
Moody and disconnected from us and you
know we would do our normal things but
we just chalked it up to hormones right
wrong or indifferent and one day you
know we had an argument about what she
was wearing she just looked
floppy and slovenly and it was just like
what is going on like what is this kind
of like you got this death five look
going on you know just it's I know you I
Emo or you goth like what is the deal
and
um we got into an argument about just
how sloppy she was looking one day and
so she went to school that day and then
in the afternoon
I got the call from the school counselor
that said I have your daughter here and
she's been cutting herself and
um you need to take care of this and we
were just mortified because this is the
kid who has access to everything
anything she wants to do not that we've
overindulged her but like for example
horses she loves horses we don't own a
horse we've never been around horses we
have paid for her to have the best
lessons as often as she needs Etc and so
it just completely pulled the rug out
from under us we found a therapist and
the therapist evaluated her on that
first day and then when she brought us
in and she said
you guys my husband and I it's just like
you guys are a helicopter parenting this
child and she needs some space you're
stifling her and we said okay we're
gonna back off tell us what you want us
to do and she said right there how did
that feel when they told you that
we were is that hard to hear we didn't
we I'm apparently here I do we disagreed
with it because our daughter had been
given a cell phone and she knew the
rules and we had told her for your
protection we are going to monitor
randomly and I told her we don't have
time we have jobs I don't want to look
at your text I don't care I don't look I
don't want to look at my own text I
don't want to look at it hold on hold on
hold on I'm just gonna stop right there
even that conversation right there Maria
is too much for a 12 year old or a 13
year old they can't they can't
cognitively process that conversation
you and I were just having
um
the therapist had said take off the
monitoring software that was a terrible
terrible terrible advice
and that's what we followed her because
she
hold on super controlling parents and we
followed her damn advice sorry no that's
what that's what it is
yes that was Dreadful advice
but it's not in a vacuum
and even the way you've painted the
conversation about she got put in in an
inpatient when she tried like really try
to take her life
it's a mad house in there it's scary oh
it's awful but hold on but y'all aren't
the victims of that
no it's the best services that your
community happened to have to take care
of your baby girl and keep her alive
is it perfect absolutely not I've been
in there more times than I can count be
sitting with people
but to leave and go well they did all of
this stuff to us and reframe this in a
victim's light or this this you got I'm
gonna tell you right now you got
terrible advice here's what the advice
should have been no phones
a 13 year old who is trying to figure
out who she is and is spinning out of
control needs her parents to stop all
the chaos not to take the brakes off
what your kid desperately desperately
desperately needs is her mom and her dad
not hey we've got all this we've got all
this here you can you see them saying
there's a difference there and I'm not
saying any of this is causal okay none
of this caused this thing
but what I'm trying to give you as a
path
out especially in in concert with
professionals
um
and the phone go ahead go ahead see so
the just
to be clear what the timeline Within
three to four weeks weeks or that with
her seeing this therapist few times a
week
um that's when she attempts a suicide
and like all the therapist and she was
just done she was just like
so apologetic she just she said I didn't
see it coming and
you know my daughter was talking with
her so
so here here's here's the unfortunate
place we find ourselves
um
we'll link to it in the show notes
there's a what I would call a
masterpiece book by Dr Gabor mate and
his uh another child psychiatrist
um and it's something along the lines of
hold on to your kids I think it's called
see if we can find that title of that
book
um
but it's co-written with somebody else
here's here's the premise of the book
you're going to hear from mental health
professionals you're going to hear from
school officials you're gonna hear from
everybody every YouTube Yahoo news
article or whatever telling you that the
most important people in your kid's life
when they become teens is their peers
and they need more unstructured
interactive time with their peers
that's completely nonsense that's not
how their bodies are wired okay yes yep
we agree and we've learned
learned that only the in the most
the most horrible way
um and so we're in this state now where
she is she's doing well we have better
communication I won't say that it's
perfect well no I got a 13 year old it's
never perfect it's never perfect yeah
right right and I you know we do have a
good sense of humor in our family like
you know I I will tell if I mess up on
something I'll say hey man cut me some
plaque I've I've never done this before
with this with a child you're my first
you know so yeah is there a possibility
that you or your husband or both
could alter your work schedules to where
y'all could each have a morning
breakfast once a week with her just
alone oh we do oh my God
we've always done that yeah we have game
nights we have movie night we I've
started giving her more of my time like
I will randomly when I pick her up from
school I will do the unthinkable I will
show up with her favorite Starbucks
drink which I normally because I'm on
baby step two I'm not biased so you know
and and we end up having just nice chats
we'll go for like a walk around and you
know she she has grown closer to us but
there are still she's so traumatized for
her therapist
um from that experience that there are
certain things she is just terrified to
talk about even what the therapist so we
need to get to that ASAP
yeah and she's working I've shared that
with the therapist okay and he's going
to have a family session yes as well so
we and we do we do those periodically
okay and so my my concern on that kind
of move is and again I'm I am completely
throwing spaghetti up against a wall
here okay
okay but a kid who can't verbalize
what's happening
sometimes that means it's still
happening
sometimes that means it is so close I
don't have words for it
sometimes and again
um
it can be anything from bullying at
school that is so profound that just
isn't fully understood it can be you
have another adult male living in your
house it can be any number of things
combination and those things too and
anything
but getting to that
where your daughter feels safe enough to
start begin beginning to start talking
about some of this stuff
let me go back to the beginning question
here
your child's mental health and mental
well-being is more important than
getting out of debt your child being
alive is more important than
that goal right now
I'm not suggesting you go borrow a bunch
of money I don't think you need to do
that but but
yes your kids health comes first does
that mean you go buy a horse no that
doesn't mean you go buy a horse
that does mean that your kid gets a job
and begins to help out with horse
lessons or dance lessons or whatever
things you're going to do
that does mean
like in this one phone call if you go
back and listen to it
the victim of this a victim of this and
now we're a victim of a 13 year old kid
at some point I want you Marie to take
ownership and your husband to take
ownership of this house
I I we are going to be the most
important people in the lives to our
daughter
and we're not going to do that through
Force feeding we're going to do that
through connection
and man there's all kinds of mess going
on and there's a there is a spike in
suicide the last numbers I saw
um it's been a minute since I looked at
them but it's there is a spike and there
is a Lost Sea of middle school kids like
a Lost Generation of kids who the last
few years of their elementary schools in
coveted lockdown and it's a mess I've
got a middle schooler I get it I talk to
middle school kids all the time
it's a mess
but I'm not going to attach all that
mess to my kid
and if I got to pull my kid out of a
school I'm going to pull my kid out of a
school and I'm not going to give my kid
a smartphone
I'm not going to give my kid unfettered
access to bullies 24 7 365 and that
hurts my child I know that it doesn't
hurt them it it makes them uncomfortable
it makes them a pariah it makes them an
outsider I get that
but the data is too clear for me
and I'm not gonna blame and I'm not
gonna blame him I'm not going to blame
I want you to start thinking about
things that aren't going to be random
that might be very very structured
because it sounds like with this baby
girl could use a healthy dose of is some
significant structure on Mondays we do
this and on Tuesdays we do this and on
Wednesdays we do this and it's going to
be a practice a practicing of
structure
I think that might be good for the whole
family obviously 100 continue on with
the um
with the with your counselor with your
therapist and for every therapist
listening for God's sake it is never the
right move for a 12 or 13 or 14 year old
for you to tell their parents actually
we need you to back off even more and
let them have unfettered access you are
overbearing checking on their phones
that's insane
absolutely insane
I'm not giving my kids access to the
open internet and all the Predators and
all the nonsense and all just had a call
a minute ago about how I can't control
myself how am I gonna expect my child to
no no thank you no thank you
Maria continue to plug in your kid man
continue to plug in and don't break the
bank
buying things
obviously pay for rehab and they expect
that if she needs to go get go get
professional help but
um
let's sit down take a global look at
your daughter's Health her mental health
all the things all all we need to do
there
and let's make sure the whole family's
plugged in because there's man
something's not right something's not
sitting right with me and hopefully the
therapist can dig that out